hey welcome back to new rockstars news
folks we got some big disney streaming
service news this week including new
Marvel and Star Wars shows and there's a
lot of big updates on Captain Marvel The
Walking Dead and more I'm Erik Voss
joining me today are Sam basher and Phil
Amelita oh hi fans again and let's get
started okay we got some big news about
the upcoming Disney streaming service
starting with its name officially it
will be called Disney Plus now it won't
work exactly like Netflix instead of
will be divided into big categories
Disney Pixar Marvel Star Wars and
National Geographic now Disney movies
will hop from Netflix to Disney Plus but
the remaining Netflix Marvel series will
stay put for now I guess they're trying
to make it a family-friendly thing at
Disney Plus Marvel Netflix series tend
to be a bit r-rated so that's just where
things are at cowards now that sounds
great but really here's the exciting
stuff Tom Hiddleston is confirmed to
play Loki in an upcoming Loki limited
series and it will be separate from the
Scarlet Witch limited series that we've
talked about before and of course don't
forget about the Bucky Falcon team of
series and by the way we just loved this
mashup picture we had two uses from at
reality Avengers we found it
thank you but Tom Hiddleston tweeted
that there's more stories to tell and
more mischief to make I'm not like doing
it sarcastically I'm just quoting him I
don't like saying quote unquote it's so
weird
but what do you guys think this show
will be about specifically it's Loki's
show like what do you think the episodes
will yeah like where in the timeline
could it take place
stop it probably I'm hoping because
these have to be so expensive these
actors fewer maybe six even we were
pitching last week I'm like Sherlock has
a really good formula of like two hour
episodes 3 apiece and that's a season
right are you getting like you can't
really be right there yeah that's
interesting
that'd be a good way to do it so I'd
sign up with Sam's idea thank you in
terms of content I gotta wonder I think
still gonna go down the redemption path
I think that's been done right I kind of
want to see Loki is like act 1 Loki that
we've seen he's like he's getting into
stuff that he probably shouldn't be you
know stealing stuff or something yeah
and he's also there's there's there's
some wiggle room for like the timeline
of where you could tell the story make
it the cosmic adventure you pointed out
last week that was like I was like oh
you have like three tiers here you have
like your three verticals for different
types of Marvel shows you got your
cosmic you got your like weird powered
one and then you got your spy more
grounded storyline over there like you
get you have some variety of where the
stories could go and if you went with
Thomas Tom Thomas it'll slow Tommy Hitty
Tommy he'd you could go with a big a
grand space epic you could do something
with cosmic characters already know or
you could introduce some of the weirder
ones and you can play around with it
because the flora franchise has already
kind of blade with the weirder I was
about to say I have a feeling that
they're gonna lean into thor ragnarok
version of her tone at least and that
means he's probably gonna get a little
sidekick is my guess maybe core right
like I'm serious and it probably will be
like you know that uh there often are
these bad guys centered things that are
if as long as they lean toward comedy a
little bit it ends up kind of working
out like cuz we don't want that
you know guilt driven stories are pretty
boring they can be it but I think could
be done really well if you look at you
like the good place you know it's it's a
redemption story distance yeah and and
it deals with a lot of like afterlife
cosmic stuff and I think there could be
a version of the Loki story that's still
kind of a Redemption thing but maybe
just like repay some literal debt you
know like yeah we're in order to do that
he has to like use his mischief to screw
over like some king somewhere out of his
wealth maybe but you could uh you eat
his entire every single arc is always is
he bad yeah kind of by the end of it and
so just do that for a series you could
have him teaming up with someone
somebody threw out the idea of like beta
ray bill so you get a cosmic character
that's weird-looking so you're like what
does that mean like how are they gonna
pull that off I'll be willing to watch
the show to see what this horseface
person looks like and also he's got a
hammer as well so you still have as
guardian ties but he is more he's an
alien so you get to go visit other
worlds it'd be fun to get some world
jumping and be fun to get other weirdos
like Jeff Goldblum's character which
could be a very fun addition yester yeah
well or maybe since he popped up on
Sekar like weeks before Thor got there
which was rewatch
I totally missed that part of the movie
but I finally caught that I'm like oh
you could do a story on Sekar so you see
all of the weird misfit alien misfit
toys that pop up on that planet and
there's a lot of colors and stuff to
play with and since thor ragnarok was so
successful for them critically and from
fans
it wouldn't be the worst thing the world
like you guys are saying visit that
specific story I've a question about
scale how big do you want these stories
to be because if it is those you know
each episode is almost two hours long or
something
Sherlock style or it's a 12-episode
series on man
those tend to have different kind of
tone to them and that feel of like oh
it's an epic adventure we have to save
the universe or is it like Loki needs
his lucky rabbit's paw back like yeah
I'm thinking like a doctor who'll ever
level scale per episode like something
that feels like it could go to the edge
of the universe but almost in a
Hitchhiker's Guide to my own way but
where it doesn't feel like oh the
universe is that think of the risk of
being ripped in half no I I think by
contrast and what the other shows to be
more grand especially the Bucky Falcon
one I would love just a spy thriller and
what it's like hey we're trying to stop
you know sd-6 sort of like the the
criminal organization or something or
like we're trying to save the world as
spies I think in spy thriller in the way
the Americans is especially like small
little things yeah mission but with kind
of big worlds implications but on an
intimate level I'm gonna get a title of
one of a marvel story a slightly
incorrect I believe it's like the Omega
sanction or something like that you know
throwing up greek-letter and then a fun
like action named after that but the
idea of it behind it would be really
good for like a grounded story like the
bucky falcon show it's they in the comic
it's between punisher daredevil and
spider-man and they find a like one of
the Fantastic Four like pucks like their
logo and it's the unstable moral
molecule so it can kind of be whatever
you want it's the story demands it it's
a flash drive that has like all like
basically all every like mobs
information all saved on it basically
they all kind of came to an agreement
they were going to save it on something
that they knew could like hold all that
information securely and all three of
them got their hands on it and so each
of them wants to use them for different
reasons so what if you took that had
like aim or Hydra or somebody else like
all vying for this like thing that like
stores a lot of information it would the
best person to go after that would be
more grounded heroes and so having Bucky
who's more like willing to kind of like
go the extra mile that kind of like kill
people and Falcon kind of being more a
little bit more straight edge you can
compare in comparison you could get a
really fun story out of that well it's
what both the Mission Possible and James
Bond franchise did recently where the
it's essentially these syndicates where
it's like you know you have the names of
everyone all around the world yeah
that'd be in chendo so we could be
episodic I just realized how not as
original that is but yeah that's very
much like oh yeah you're right it's a
trope because it works like even it's
the first mission impossible I look back
as ivory watch that movie it's about
like the FBI asset list that's right
they're just trying to prevent that from
getting out and I think it does maybe I
can yeah I mean I think what we want to
see is scarlet witch's show what are we
thinking I mean like is it like charmed
or is it you know like when did you come
out cuz we don't know how long it's
gonna take to even announce these shows
to get a cast going to production like
we don't know what the timetable or
which one will come out first yeah for
me I would say if x-men are joining and
you start to like kind of like lay your
the groundwork for it okay so Sam would
be amazing over there but that's almost
a movie phase for
no no no I mean I mean Scarlet Witch is
role like you know yeah I guess I are
you imagining that that storyline should
ever mean oh then no more yeah uh for me
no because I've read that story in its
it doesn't quite get me so excited but
it's not a bad story that you'd imagine
if you introduced the x-men and then
immediately take away all mutant powers
be a bummer exactly with having the
first episode of Inhumans it all didn't
watch it so I remember the only one who
did well but there's also some Star Wars
news too from Disney plus a new series
focused on casseon and or that was do
diga Lunas character in rogue one the
show will be a rebel spy thriller and
will take place before rogue one
obviously thinks in and too well for him
at the end of that movie and this is in
addition by the way to Jon Favreau's the
Mandalorian show that will take place
long after that good it sounds great
and there also be Monsters Inc series
sounds like a great workplace comedy
there in the high school musical series
which
sounds honestly pretty cool especially
it's like I mean I was a fan of Glee you
know start us something new yeah
basically this is gonna be huge you're
something for everyone so many favorite
things in one place right the whole Star
Wars Pixar High School Musical oh boy
national what about you guys are there
any like obscured Disney properties you
want to see you get a new life on this
thing do you think this whole thing is
sustainable too we're talking about that
second be good because it's faster
answer I think or at least right now for
me is I don't know if it is sustainable
to go this hard this this fast and and
this big because my biggest issue with
that I think is the fact that if all of
these especially with the Marvel stuff
if all these things keep getting shows
like then the movies stop feeling a
special and they stop feeling these huge
events so I think like you know maybe
maybe it is like Sherlock Sherlock has
those seasons and then you wait I think
17 years between use your children like
maybe if they do it that way could work
but sustainable in terms of like a
Netflix tile pace absolutely I think
it's only sustainable if they do limited
seriously they just use six episodes and
done of a Loki high budget Loki series
yeah and that's it if anything it's more
in competition with the other TV
networks like cable providers and CBS
ABC well ABC zone might dismay but you
know what I mean like I think the movies
were always gonna be their own thing
because it's a different thing when you
go see a movie it's like an exhibition
thing it's like going to the theater it
will always be I think this kind of
tradition maybe in a smaller form than
it is at least when we grew up and what
it is now but I don't know if a
streaming app will replace going to the
movies but I think a streaming app could
very easily replace television George
Clinton weirdly was on the underneath or
somebody was and he was like I'm tired
of all the damn streaming apps and I was
like this is just you just started to
cry a little bit what I would want to
see though like I would love seeing some
Pixar shows like take a new life I think
there'd be a fix off Pixar movies like I
think Finding Nemo would be a good one
for that there's no way they don't make
a cars something like there's no way
they don't do that like cause like item
I might not like it but I might not they
might not be for me but kids love them
well it'd be great for one of the ones
it's a little tapped out on the movie
run right like cars has kind of
not everywhere they do have cars
terrorist attacks go watch our video the
world of cars explain dark truths of
cars that be fun to get into I think
maybe they could do John Carter of Mars
correctly because they own that they
really wanted that to be there they also
own sister act so yeah by the way I'm
not kidding like a sister act reboot
again it'd be like Glee but with nuns
will be urban youth that's only suspect
to has urban youth in it right you don't
want the urban youth you just want the
night I like the urban youth but it's
only one of the sister acts well they
stablish the universe and then they move
forward from there that's right say the
ninety still you're good to go
yeah who was the singer who got from
from the Fugees Lauryn Hill Whoopi
Goldberg was not discovered in the
second Goldberg oscar-winning Whoopi
Goldberg from Green has to move on the
Protestants are asking us to move on
from the nuns okay so as always our
punishment is the gift of shame and our
tribute question this week is named
these characters left to right oh no no
okay well our high school musical
knowledge was put to the test and I
don't think we passed it but all our
answers are here I'm speaking for myself
over here in this blue bucket at the end
of the episode we'll reveal what the
answer is and who want it and the loser
will have to do or get yes always if
you're good with crafts maybe send us a
replacement for a bucket never shame box
or never gets a member of the family
don't you dare I don't have the heart to
tell rocket and I won't need it anymore
been in the family for a long time
speaking of a long time ago figured a
segue Sister Act but no anyways I want
to talk about Captain Marvel for a
second because the Disney Japan website
revealed this week the Captain Marvel
will be set in 1995 who we knew would be
the night a year that was announced but
now this is the first time we're having
a this is the first time we have an
official year sorry the chair started
moving away from me
this works with a lot of few things that
we've seen in the trailer like carol
danvers crashes through even one monster
video not a blockbuster and that rebrand
actually took place in 1996 since Anna
you see a map at the LA Green Line
subway which fits because that opened in
1995 as well she's matching that green
line with that green outfit but things
are pointing out that all of the Rock
the Vote signs that we're actually from
1992 and if you zoom in enhance you can
see that underneath those posters are
some flyers for a pig fart show I am
unfamiliar with that band but it's for a
show on Thursday August 29th and August
29th fell on a Thursday in 1991 and 1996
so what you guys know tune it may be
that they're old only thing is obviously
the rock the boat posters don't look but
also this could just be an advance
notice for a show taking place for the
following year you know you want to get
um some hype or the rock the boats could
be for the next year you know you start
getting the word out and during the
primary seasons in 95 yeah that makes
sense wait so it's a reiterate so yeah I
think do you think these are older
posters do you think there's Rock the
Vote one wood we did you establish that
hmm yes here during when it started and
they do it every election year yeah
right so it would be in 96 was an
election year they would put up the boat
yeah that design okay so they were out
of the new posters right
they pulled the old ones out of there
out of their stock but more than that
what do you guys think of the
significance of the year in 1995 that's
more that's so that's a big in 1985
across the Marvel Universe Marvel stuff
is going on okay so the Starks are dead
that was 91 so you know shield was
the missing Starks in Tony Stark was
probably going through college or still
a young young whippersnapper 95 would be
I think that's a year where Thanos
conquered gamora's home planet boria
yeah I usually just say it quick
yeah a pass and everything saturate our
world thank you for the fun fact that we
learned that was the year that Bill
Clinton confirmed that area 51 is a real
place so maybe that lines up with the
alien crash landing in our world yeah
honestly so yeah when area 51 wasn't a
lot of people thought that it was like
trying to cover up scandal stuff but
honestly if it does the crash landing
that like Reap so if you don't they were
51 story right like famously in the 50s
supposedly there was a crash landing and
then you know area 51 like I guess is
where the remains of that crash landing
are if for some reason a second alien
crash landing or something is the reason
that both Larry 51 existed yeah harder
to hide when something crash lands in a
blockbuster video tougher yeah it's
anyway and maybe that's why they they
were just propped up by the government
the government did know to keep up with
competition like red box and Netflix and
that's why it crashed also in our world
the OJ Simpson verdict oh yeah that's it
what she's huge that that hopefully will
at least get reference I'm sure get a
sack yeah we don't get me straight at
some point she's got to put some gloves
and you know wait for me okay I think
that Bill Clinton area 51 I think that
might be the easy it's really the most
fascinating because we're talking about
like a Secret Invasion potentially right
that's the story of the scroll you know
filling in society and imposing its
people and one entity to take a chapter
out of Independence day's book if you
remember sorry 51 players were all in
that movie but specifically on the this
invasion that we're currently having a
having the scientist says ever since
this started all this stuff here started
to turn back on all right the idea of
like the stuff to Roswell and stuff yes
oh yeah so if it is you know Scrolls
came in the 50s been here the whole time
yeah and then yeah I mean there's also a
very decent chance that they're not
gonna reference know yeah and they were
just like no it took place you know in
the 90s and we want in 90s is in what
okay
to counter that it would have been more
significant for this movie to do it I
feel like for fans in 1998 so that it
was there was a ten-year gap between the
first Iron Man movie and then this and I
feel like the events of those I feel
like it would've been a cool mirror
image of like okay moving forward
Black Panther Captain Marvel and doctor
changes the name they always start or
spider-man being like our new three or
four that we want to push and I feel
like if you wanted to make it more
significant you would've picked a date
like that so 95 has more significance
with this area 51 comment okay I have a
question then all right so the movie
said I agree that 98 would be very
interesting what about Captain Marvel
sequels would they want to do the kind
of Wonder Woman thing where it still
keeps taking place in the past we've
always assumed at the end of Captain
Marvel will end with her getting sent
out in space when there's like you know
whatever reason is she's not available
now but maybe she is still around in 96
and in 97 and in 98 or do you think that
they're gonna set Captain Marvel sequels
post infinity war like they'll catch up
the way they did with like Captain
America and then it ends with him in the
present day I think I would I would
prefer that honest me - it'll be fun
but what if Avengers 4 we've talked
about so many different theories of the
ventures for what if it just takes place
removed from time in space and logic and
it's so like yeah she could still fight
along with them in the present day sort
of and another reality but then may be
of interest for ends with everyone just
going back to where they came from or
back from the time they came back to
when they came from including Captain
America including Captain Marvel so
maybe so and essentially you're just
dropping a theory they're right that the
that her role is more because of the
time stone that that she's able to take
place in this energy where different
realities - like there's so many
different ways this could go for sure so
so that could be a reason why they'd if
they wanted a buffer but yeah that's
really understand I don't know where
that that would happen those sequels in
my head I was like oh you know she can
go into space and she'll freeze and then
the own freezer for infinity where I'm
like that's exactly but I think I think
I'm with you guys where I just wanted to
jump in on the action and join in
because what she just it's always gonna
be with Sam Jackson getting but also I
do want to go back to that idea of Danos
you know doing what he did on commercial
yeah because did that like sense some
kind of like blip on the radar like did
shield believe in their activities when
they're like oh there's this mad Titan
or were they completely blind I think
she's exactly because she's part of an
intergalactic he call it space this is
not space force but they call it was
Star Force that's what it was Star Force
and so they they could be more like the
Green Lantern's where they're going out
and they're like taking care of other
planets as well or maybe they're not and
they get word of this and they go out
and they start sending out scouts of
like oh this person's like having the
populations of planets like we have to
do something she gets a knock on the
noggin and she's out well do we know how
long ago that OSes plan started we don't
we what's weird because he already had
the mine stone and we don't know the
story of how we got that mines does it
cuz say you know gamora's home planet
was a pilot run of like you know doing
this whatever and then he's like he does
that and then it's essentially out there
he's going to every plan and he's gonna
do a version of this if he can't get the
stones he's just gonna go planet by
planet return to your home planets and
go protect your home planet maybe
there'll be some kind of Captain Marvel
movie maybe this one or some future one
that ends with the Kree fighting in the
sand our battles prevent Thanos from
getting the Power Stone it's a story
that we know happened but we didn't see
it go down and you know I kind of want
to see Xander gets destroyed it happens
all the time
yeah only kind of makes all the time
they don't care about that oh no defense
yeah so I want to see that battle you
want to see how he got it why do you
think she doesn't have a memory and you
said that he has the mind stone so that
would be kind of interesting to see the
my son being you cuz he doesn't use it
movie besides yeah the same time he was
kicked in the head with that be though
I'm Marvel's part we're like oh we're
watching Captain Marvel and it's so
disconnected from infinity war and yet
she's about to be so essential in
infinity war part 2 if Thanos makes a
cameo yeah that would be a great idea
unbeliev airy smart I feel like that'd
be a very smart move and it also doesn't
have to you can still watch that movie
and just understand that this is a
person that's going to be a threat in a
future Martin Captain Marvel be and it
doesn't it doesn't you know it doesn't
you don't need to know anything going
yeah he doesn't have to be like from his
whole storyline he could be just like
you know hanging out on earth like
getting commercial work or whatever
[Laughter]
like an advice he's like a jazz player
or like the after shot after grimace
stopped eating McDonald's yeah what you
could be well let us know in the
comments down below what your theories
are for why Captain Marvel needs to take
place in the nineties they put it there
in it for a reason do you think we hid
it somewhere in this conversation or do
you have some other ideas but what else
happened this week some other big news
happened and yeah this was a huge week
for The Walking Dead I know that you
know so and you guys have talked to us
about like oh are you guys doing Walking
Dead or not and I've tried to be really
honest because I asked me but I think
it's just been you know the Walking Dead
fan base has been shrinking and it does
show up in in our view count if you go
watch any Walking Dead video we've done
you kind of see that that it was more
expensive for us to make that than
anything we got back from it but we we
have tried to talk about it when it's
been relevant so we did something about
what happened this week which was
supposed to be what we all thought was
gonna be Rick Grimes is death and he
definitely has last episode so spoiler
alert for exactly what happened here if
you're not caught up on Walking Dead and
you want to get caught up but he's been
a character since since the beginning
Rick Grimes played by Andrew Lincoln he
did have what is being called his final
episode but here's a spoiler instead of
dying like everyone does in Walking Dead
at some point you either turn or you or
you get killed another way he flew off
to be in movies apparently in the
pictures he was literally actually
though airlifted away in a helicopter
and he and they announced immediately I
got the email as I was watching it that
he is going to star in a trilogy of
Walking Dead made-for-tv movies which
we've all not been clamoring for so in
the comics you know we have the comics
we have a Walking Dead TV show we have
fear of The Walking Dead and now we're
gonna have this Walking Dead movie
trilogy so you did that deep dive you
guys can go check out it's called cars
but you can also check out Rick's lineup
so deep dive go check that out but I
thought it's worth it like this I did
watch and I really actually thought it
was a very interesting moment on the
show so we should take a minute to talk
about just where the Walking Dead
universe is as a whole right now because
they did make some major changes
specifically for a second let's focus on
this idea of him going to go deep these
movies there was some reports there's
just little hints and clues he said
something about how he's always been
really interested in what the
government's been doing and what the
institution institutional response has
been they do have a helicopter does seem
like they could be going that route
which could finally potentially bring us
back onto a path about a potential cure
they had that season two storylines
because it's what it was when they went
to the CDC and they were you know the
other season one yeah yeah exactly it's
going but they very much have not wanted
to do that right they wanted to be like
we're The Walking Dead and have that
like yeah human experience to me that
gets more the new ever evolves version
of the human species but I mean it
there's this really interesting question
out there where it's like what happened
to the government you know are there
scientists out there still working on it
is there still mode well when Eugene
Eugene pitches them the whole idea of I
can get you to what if you need me to
Washington DC I'm a scientist I don't
anymore after he told me that he was not
a scientist I just know yeah I think
there was some kind of glimmer of hope
there like oh this guy he might actually
cuz he mentioned having contact with
like underground surviving government
forces who are in the DC area he was
also wired he was a completely so I
guess my question split more
specifically is do you guys think that
it's gonna go that route and be a little
bit more high-level instead of trying to
just do exactly what Walking Dead and
fear The Walking Dead have already done
and if not do you think what else are
what do you think it's gonna be these
movies I think it's actually this is
kind of a cool direction if you wanted
to kind of spice up well what the
Walking Dead is making right now like
they're still still a successful not
what they used to be so I'm I'm on board
with this idea also by the way they
announced this week the Breaking Bad
movie that's yeah and some people were
like oh is it confirmed it's about Jesse
but yeah yeah and but a lot of people
were like does that mean cinema movie or
is that TV movie and I'm like hey if
they're famous he wants to keep making
these TV movies - maybe compete with
Netflix or something that's not a bad
idea
launch a streaming app and I'll kill
myself
yeah I think you know Robert Kirkman the
guy who created the comic series has
said that he never wants Walking Dead
and he wants it to be kind of like Star
Trek which is like open-ended this is
the world as it is now and we'll see how
society of all I'm sure you're real
happy to keep that going
however I do believed in Robert Kirkman
part ways at least with AMC the network
or he's no longer as I know he liked
them because of plot reasons honestly he
was like I don't want to be associated
so they're kind of freed up Scott Gimple
is really overseeing the entire brand
for AMC and I wouldn't be surprised if
they do go in that direction
I mean if you watched a video one of the
things I go into is this whole idea if
you're watching this season the whole
idea of what is an a and what does it be
like Jadis or an is the one who called
the helicopter and the guy on the radio
is like oh do you have an A or do you
have a B and it sounds like a s are more
valuable and that Rick at one point was
an A but is not anymore that it could be
men and women and they're trying to like
potentially populate maybe but then
Gabriel she goes all this time I thought
you were be saying he's an a some people
are like well doesn't mean alpha leader
it's like there's no way gave us more of
an alpha Britta's so what the theory is
that I think is most interesting is that
an a is a person who has been infected
by a walker but it's not turned yet
which is a very rare and valuable thing
that they would want to experiment on
because someone like Rick is a survivor
he's strong like Carl Stata infected for
like 24 hours at least
that's why would they need a helicopter
to airlift him out of there quickly get
him to wherever they need to go so then
quickly extremely think he's infected I
think to be an a that's what she called
him Abby she goes I don't have an AI
just have a bee and Rick got on a
helicopter but she whenever she said to
Gabriel I thought you were be alright
after that she does that thing with us
she almost did to negan and she puts a
walker on him on like this cart till I
tried to bite him so people were
thinking oh they don't want to she
doesn't want to kill him she just wants
to you know give him a little scratch so
still though then government
experimental government experiments to
try to derive a cure from maybe some of
the more stronger survivors try to
derive a cure from that's at least one
movie you're thinking that's one movie
or three well what's super interesting
though about it to me is
that World War Z yes I am legend the way
that ends right well I am Legend ends
with their rightful World War Z is it's
the CDC it becomes our hero's right or
tries to ever again World War Z is very
different from the book but both of
these apply it so in World War Z the
movie Brad Pitt tries to save us all by
using science and Penny yeah but and and
that has that interesting institutional
thing but World War Z the book is the
diaries of people who have survived
theoretically because of somebody
printed this and put it together
survived a zombie apocalypse but it goes
through like we see what it's like to be
on a submarine you know we see what
happens when the walkers in this case
what happens when they get to the ocean
do they can they do they die they float
do they walk on the on the bottom of it
it just examines all these different
pockets of our institutions in our
society I think that'd be so cool to do
over three movies potentially yeah so I
actually finally got a little more
excited about it so seeing more of the
world like that that could be of the
Walking Dead yeah it's real quicker
there any other pictures you guys think
would be a better use of these three
movies that's the best pitch I've heard
so far right when you say Curie is
interesting but then you I know why I
don't follow Walking Dead but I do know
what happens at the end of this episode
cuz everyone's talking about it and so
when you talk about a cure that doesn't
quite I don't know if that makes total
sense with what they're setting up so
this is a spoiler talking you get to
jump forward in time so it's like is
that does that lineup still do you a
would you guys be okay if they actually
figured that out right what is tough to
cuz timeline wise from what we
understand it probably is gonna take
place so if you didn't notice this too
in The Walking Dead episode at the end
there's a time jump of a few years again
and it feels like they're kind of
rebooting the show a little bit so it
could be a good jumping on point by the
way if you're thinking about getting
back into it if his entire three movies
take place inside of that time job then
they definitely don't end with a cure so
you got a hope that they don't start
with the search for a cure because
you're like well I know it doesn't end
with one I may be the first one only
takes place during that time line maybe
the second one takes place you know
later these pin things are probably not
going to come out to like 2022 yeah we
got some time I haven't liked the idea
of what if it took place because if it
if they do need infected people where
would they be where they wouldn't have
infected people I'm thinking what if
they're on an island
like there's there in the DC area
there's the island of Roanoke you know
the famous Lost Colony right where the
so what if like that becomes an
innovation yeah I would love to see some
kind of Island colony what I thought
Oceanside was going to be but now it's
just kind of like literally Oceanside
that supposed to like some island nation
that we don't really see at this point
the comics I'd love to see some kind of
island people where they they went there
they were able to stay quarantined virus
and but they they're interested in seen
zombies yeah another way to put that is
that if there's institutional
institutions that can fall again
because that was my most excited feeling
about fear The Walking Dead was we were
gonna see our society collapse and it
collapsed so fast it was like a like oh
yeah you right it was a few episodes but
we just saw in these very small examples
but I loved remember that moment of
their watching on their phones in class
yeah and I was like man yeah it totally
disrupted finals yeah but like like I
love that moment so if this could do
that again maybe it is there's an island
that they do have government and
hierarchy and stuff and we can watch it
all fall apart again yeah a happy ending
exactly yeah a smile on the face well
yeah let us know what you think in the
comments below where you want this
series this whole Walking Dead brand to
go and whether it should merge with fear
The Walking Dead or you want that to be
its own thing or you don't know what
fear The Walking Dead is what else
happened this week oh there's a lot of
news so in other news eight's shield
fun fact is apparently more popular than
the Netflix Marvel shows a KO during
recording yeah to some parrot analytics
data that measures things other than
actual ratings like file sharing and
social media so it's the brand is more
popular and more known as far as Netflix
or network television has a lot more
reach I think which is amazing that it
still is that considering people talk
about oh everything the Netflix
everything's happening there whatever
but actually normal TV especially non
cable like ABC right over the big 3 or
big 4 now with Fox that reaches every
household in America and all in its own
way more frequently so just it means
there's a lot more calm but also gene
smart and Jeremy Irons are both the
been confirmed to be cast and the new
watchmen HBO series from damon lindelof
both of those casting that both yeah
excited I think it's gonna be good I
think so no wouldn't really go and also
it was announced that Jeremy Irons gonna
be playing an older version of
Ozymandias which is very cool whatever
that's going to be it's probably not
gonna end up well for him but also
Aquaman has some test screenings and
they're yielding mostly positive reviews
so just good but Pokemon detective
Pikachu their test screenings have been
receiving extremely positive reviews
like so good that we're talking about it
on the show I thought this at first the
movies sound interesting and then I
heard more news and I'm like oh oh well
this will look kinda like Pikachu's
shock Wow
but also speaking of new movies coming
out Bill Hader says that it too is
surprisingly emotional which is kind of
fun news and also interesting news Tom
Hanks says that the ending of Toy Story
4 will change cinema boy cinema cinema
movies what could that be like what do
you guys think that could actually the
toys gonna like burst out of screen like
that thing in the Muppet movie like if
it breaks the cinema is it like will be
on camera no every time you watch the
movie you are a different toy in that
movie you your face is on it or when one
of the toys eyes
a drop falls on you and I got it it
merges with the Chucky Universe good I'm
Hanks most ambitious cross forget my
genuine guess is only that and I don't
want it to be this is that they the
people discover the toys yeah oh yeah
but what that change cinema or just
changed the cinematic universe the toys
I don't know if it became about like oh
my god we've been enslaving a whole
sentient history yeah yeah if they yeah
yeah I know it's it's real we already
figured that out twenty years later and
you know they're everyone's there's some
ladies
the first Toy Story changed cinema I
mean why do you have to have two movies
in a franchise cinema it's in play yeah
and go see play tickets yeah okay well
I'm gonna watch it both these movies
sounds great too as well if you read in
a book of course it's emotional well
let's move on to Jeff's new rockstars
news lightning round question alright
but I'm gonna do the question but these
do not I drop them all they're all oh
well thank you all so much for tweeting
us your questions it's always
appreciated we love hearing from you are
you guys ready yeah Sam at stuff Fortis
oh how do you think fawns and everyday
people will react to a three-hour elf
and everyday people will react to a
3-hour Avengers movie I'll ask for more
of course I never wanted to end Eric at
original Huggy are you an A or a B hash
like The Walking Dead good thing we
defined that I'm a I'm a B baby for me
at Roberts pucker do you think we're
gonna get an Avengers for treilery Game
of Thrones Season eight trailer first
Avengers 4 trailer first I think
Avengers 4 trailer oh I want to say
before Thanksgiving oh man Eric at Silva
film critic if you could enter the world
of any movie no matter what the genre
what one would be very proud our
universe the awesome iron P what movie
have you enjoyed the most this year
instant family and I can't talk more
about it which is a bummer oh well but
because you but you can soon or whatever
so stay on your socials at Sam boy and a
duck if you could dine with won Game of
Thrones character who would it be and
why dine with Robert King Robert that
guy would have like a feast and an orgy
and all of it samih
at top zachary if you had the Infinity
Gauntlet with all six stones how would
you use it
one way you would use I would let I
would let everyone have a pool in their
backyard a pool in every yard does not
bring back the half the University myth
Eric underscored charge Jensen sorry
setting aside video games for a moment
Eric lists your top five favorite
tabletop games which iw oh yeah yeah ok
pandemic I I love I love Lords of
Waterdeep I love Puerto Rico seven
wonders and throw in a classic sadly I
hate that one but no you were just too
good at it and I got annoying at on
kolenka what do you think about the
upcoming Breaking Bad movie I'm actually
pretty nervous about it but I'm really
excited to see Vince Gilligan go into
movies
cuz he's stuck on this Albuquerque
universe I'm curious to see how like
like if this is gonna be a bridge we'll
finally get him he could be a Cohen
brother like he's at oh yeah so I'm
excited that he's doing a movie but I'm
also a little bit like it ended
perfectly alone Eric at drop man AV what
movie did you watch more than 10 times
more than 10 times for this job I've
definitely seen the Dark Knight more
than 10 times easily in Inception
good burger yeah Sam at Jeffrey
understood Carter if you could elect one
superhero to be your state's
representative in the Senate who would
you pick Captain America Kathryn
America's corn you could travel 50 years
into the past 50 years into the future
to live what I don't even need to look
50 years in the future I'm obsessed with
future tech I made a video on a whole
different channel about the future and
the robots taking over you should go
watch cars
thank you let's move on to our 15-second
shout outs where each of us is 15
seconds to shout out plug a random
ramble about anything we want Sam oh oh
so say it it's it's sensible gun control
laws please that's all I want and I
today I had a nice discussion actually
with it with a fan and I didn't mind it
but I just want to say that everyone's
right there are million causes to these
things there's a million things that we
could be doing but only one of them
could we'll start working tomorrow and
that's just just hurdles right gun
control laws are just hurdles to try to
make it harder please write to your
representatives hopefully we can make
that happen to you all the above yeah
yes do ever young link to all of them
just the one that starts tomorrow good
lord
it's always sunny there finale this year
was incredible and I mean that in
comedic ly and they did something
extremely bold it is a Mac and finds his
pride and I 100% recommend it you could
actually watch it without even watching
the rest of the show it would mean more
if you have watched the show but you
could still just watch it yeah go watch
it um and for my plug I've been plugging
it all the time I'm doing my live Marvel
parody show infinity fan round two and
we're tightening some stuff up we've
heard some new material we've got some
new cast members it's really fun if you
live in the LA area or if you know
someone who does who likes to go see
shows come check it out and check out
the ticket info in the description below
come meet me in person you can ask me
about theories if you want it's not a
Q&A yes
but yeah there's a it's just gonna be a
fun comedy night and there's music and
there's impressions and cosplay all
kinds of fun stuff Eric sings in it more
than once I think I really enjoyed so
yeah let's move on to our trivia
question that we asked this is no I love
this question
okay just because it was hard it's like
really out of our element you know
there's finally some stuff that we don't
know and who is this just remind us what
the question was name these characters a
cast of High School Musical the first
movie left to right okay so I'll start
so oh wait do we want to know what their
names are first or second okay great
okay before we see what each of us said
virtual names yeah we're gonna read the
correct answers okay so over here on the
far left we have Chad Danforth next to
him is taylor mckessie and then Zac
Efron's characters Troy Bolton too next
name is Gabriella Montez and then
Sharpay Evans and Ryan and dog it was
weird
okay so all right so Eric's guesses on
the left we got Damon we got Sasha then
we got Troy but you try then Gabby was
at Gabriella Gabriella
well you you know her so well then you
actually got Sharpay yeah and then you
got Erik Bosse age 16 yes I met you when
you were a lot older than that and you
still look Corbin Bleu not a clue you
knew Zac Efron the actor yeah and he
thought his name was Corey and then
Vanessa Hudgens Tina and then what does
that shaky Tisdale as Danny and then
obviously Eric Ross age 16 but yeah and
then no what did the Philip say here we
go running down the line got blue pants
headband ABS no legs Karen the
time-traveling Thomas Finkelstein is
this time traveler there
ding ding ding so it sounds like I
probably got closest there again you
definitely did I think you purposely got
some of them wrong so wouldn't be weird
to make you feel bad I feel great I feel
great
we're all in this together all right I
can't do stuff like I was the winner of
that one they came a little short so
folks going to join our gif of shame
Club here he's gonna pull a task or a
gesture from out of the box and he has
to do it all repeatedly as we chant
shame at him in front of our green
screen and we want you guys to swap out
him and put him in some crazy back right
it doesn't have to do exactly what he is
doing here you can make him do something
else that looks way more embarrassing
and humiliating so I have to do all
right the ground is lava ground is lava
a ground okay swap with you okay
everyone
oh you ready Phillip yeah okay so
Philips ground is lobbying but thank you
for watching this week's episode of new
rock stars news I want to thank our host
Sam bachelor at Sam bachelor on social
media Phillip Molina at fimo and Erik
Bosse myself at E a vos how's it shame
shame shame shame eating comment down
below 20 rock stars like this video
share it around dr dinner rock star chef
deep dives and all the stuff you love
see you guys next week bye bye shame
shame enjoying that rock shame
that's right we only need like three
seconds right it's got like five minute
gifts on there my by a wise upload the
video man